>>Teacher: Today we're
going to take SAT I.
>>Narrator: Tests, from
national, standardized tests
to final exams are the most
common form of student assessment.
But many educators
believe we need better ways
to measure learning and achievement.
>>Howard: People may be good test
takers but once you leave the world
of testing you have
to think for yourself
because the world doesn't
come organized in four choices
with the fourth one being
"None of the above".
>>Student: Well can I show
you something on the computer?
>>Teacher: Absolutely.
>>Narrator: Comprehensive
assessment provides ongoing feedback
so that teachers, principals,
parents and students can constantly
improve teaching and learning
on a daily and weekly basis.
>>Teacher: As far as
listening and speaking
and writing you're
making steady progress.
>>Narrator: Comprehensive
assessments provide a picture
of the whole student, and can
include more traditional measures
like multiple choice tests and essays
as well as portfolios, experiments,
and role play that
mirrors real life tasks.
>>Hi my name is Eddie Kim.
I am a site planner and thank you
for letting us propose a plan.
>>Narrator: In the Urban Plan project
students learn state standards
and economics by working in teams
to create development proposals.
>>Yeah, that's way too high.
How do we kill our percent
but still make the city go up?
>>Dong-Jin: The project as a whole,
it gets you ready for the real world.
Just looking out of the
book it gets pretty tedious,
like you're just looking in a book.
You're memorizing facts and stuff.
But once you learn how to
actually use those facts,
you get a deeper understanding and
you can better interpret questions
and so you build up like
really useful skills.
>>The number is going to be
about one point five million.
>>Narrator: While comprehensive
assessment requires a significant
amount of time and energy,
proponents insist the investment pays
big dividends.
>>Linda: Students have to
develop the performances.
The teachers have to evaluate them.
But the time is not lost
to teaching and learning.
The time is teaching and learning
because the actual conduct
of the assessment is a learning
experience for the students.
It informs teaching.
It actually gives teachers feedback
immediately about what they need
to do to meet students' needs,
so it's actually productive time.
>>In the year 2050 education
has become project-based.
>>Narrator: Comprehensive assessment
promotes student accountability
for learning, self-reflection,
and presentation skills
needed for the work world.
>>Transportation, four facts.
>>Hugh: As I was mulling all
these issues about assessment,
I was struck by the fact that there
are all other sorts of attributes
like drive and grit
and determination,
ability to problem solve,
communication skills,
leadership skills, these intangibles
that were critically important.
>>Teacher: Football field
100 yards, 300 feet.
>>Hugh: And that by virtue
of the excessive reliance
on the testing scores you're ruling
out large numbers of youngsters
of all races, and all complexions
who may not have stratospheric
test scores,
but who have these other
kinds of attributes
that experience shows contribute to
high-level success in the real world.
>>Teacher: Oh so you're just going to
have a bunch of paths through here?
>>Students: Yeah.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org